[Applause]
hey welcome to your weekly ticket work
from home edition 200,000 200,000 drive
as you probably already know a lot of
the movies in the spring theatrical
release calendar have been moved and
even some of the ones from the rest of
the year have been pushed but we finally
have some new release dates from major
studios like paramount Sony and Disney
so here's what we know
Disney's highly anticipated Mulan will
now hit theaters on July 24th that's
four months after the film was
originally set to open and Black Widow
will now have its release date on
November 6 2020 that date was of course
previously held by Eternals which will
now move to February of next year
February 12 2021 and just like eternals
this shifts a majority of the face for
Marvel movies so here is a look at the
current changes in the MCU calendar
Paramount Pictures a quiet place part 2
was one of the first films to be delayed
due to the corona virus pandemic and it
was just originally just taken
completely off the schedule but we now
have an official release date and that
September 4th just in time for Labor Day
and thankfully Hollywood is still trying
to make the best of the situation we're
all stuck in reports suggest that George
Miller is auditioning for his next Mad
Max movie talking to onion taylor joy on
a webcam about a potential role in the
film anya taylor joy is best known for
her work on emma peaky blinders and the
new mutants hearing there's potentially
no delay to the furiosa film is that's
some good news man
and I know a lot of you are stuck
indoors and there's a lot to watch but
we have some recommendations for you and
I have a special guest to help me out
today Fandango and Rotten Tomatoes
correspondent Nazz Perez hey what's your
recommendation okay so my recommendation
is onward and I thought about this for a
long time because there's so many great
movies on Fandango now and I picked
onward for two reasons first reason is
it came out on March 6 in theaters and
then obviously the theatrical run got
cut short which was a bummer and also
it's just a great movie for the entire
family and I feel like most of us are
stuck at home with our families so it's
a safe bet there but basically to story
about two magical elf brothers Ian and
barley Lightfoot and they go on this
crazy epic magical adventure just to try
and spend one more day with their dad
that passed away when they were little
I'm literally getting goose bumps
thinking about it and what's so awesome
is that actually got to sit down with
the director of the film dan scanlon and
he told me that it was inspired by his
real life because his father passed away
when he was one and he's always thought
how cool would it be if I could spend
just one day with my dad and I have
never laughed so hard and cried so hard
in the same movie in such a long time
and I feel like it's because the
bromance between Chris Pratt and Tom
Holland who boys both of the brothers
it's just so palpable like we've seen
them work together in the MCU and I just
I mean it's Pixar you know it's textbook
Pixar it's certified fresh' on Rotten
Tomatoes has a 95% audience core so I
feel like most people agree you can't go
wrong with Pixar's onward I will say you
will want to have a box of tissues next
to you though No so for my
recommendation I recommend a parasite
now if you haven't seen it try to go in
blind you shouldn't even be watching the
trailer just try and go and blind it won
Best Picture it's a really engaging film
about classism between two families I
know that doesn't sound interesting but
it's super good now if you have seen it
I recommend Yuri watch it and I
recommend you make a little activity out
of it you can get the ingredients for
Ramadan which is a dish they serve in
the movie you can get them online so you
can order it cook up some Ramadan and
rewatch parasite
and yeah it's it's really good I'm not
gonna eat it on camera because I also
have to talk after this check out
parasite check out onward Thank You Nazz
these toys are having me
[Music]
friday marks the early digital release
of Universal Pictures trolls of world
tour which will be able to see the same
day it was due out in theaters on April
10th for a premium rental price Anna
Kendrick who voices poppy shared the
news on Twitter saying I'm so happy we
can spread the joy while everyone stays
safe you can see trolls world tour on
its original release date to rent in
your own home I'll see you on April 10th
Anna Kendrick by the way has one of the
best Twitter accounts that's not news
it's just my opinion but yeah it's news
but these episodes come out on Tuesday
and maybe you want to watch something
before Friday well like a boss and never
rarely sometimes always are available to
watch now at home Rose Byrne and Tiffany
Haddish team up to play two best friends
who are trying to save their financially
struggling cosmetic business in a stroke
of good luck too good to be true an
industry Titan played by Salma Hayek
offers them a hefty buyout the beauty
business is now about to get ugly as the
proposal puts the two lifelong friends
to the ultimate test the film is
directed by Miguel Arteta who previously
worked with Salma Hayek on but trees at
dinner
never rarely sometimes always is also
available to watch at home a seventeen
year old girl named autumn played by
Sydney Flannigan winds up pregnant in a
small Pennsylvania town prevented from
seeking an abortion by the state's
parental consent laws she takes off for
New York City with her cousin Skylar
played by Talia Ryder where what they
would assume would be a one-day
procedure proves considerably more
complicated and the film is certified
fresh' with a 99% on Rotten Tomatoes all
right well that's all I got for you this
week before you go leave us a comment to
let us know what you're watching
anything we should catch up on and I
will see you guys next Tuesday see you
later
[Music]